Scott doing something your your Artistry
in this fashion is so special so unique
having the album and this television
event together as sort of as one piece
you know and I know that you've had
impatient fans like tweeting at you
waiting like when is it gonna happen for
you after all these years of waiting and
work how's it feel to actually have it
out here
oh man I'm the the first thing I saw
when I saw it two months ago
there was relief you know to see it
completed and see that my vision was
executed uh to to what I wanted and and
also to be where I'm at right now I'm
just feeling like
accomplished like because
I know that you know when you have
something that you know is good you know
and it's like right before it comes out
and you're just like I know it's good
you know you just have this confidence
you know and that's where I feel like
that's where I'm at with with this show
you know it's just
you know
we put like you said three years into
this it took so much time I mean shout
out to Jessica for making time at her
schedule she's been filming movies and
doing all this stuff and she's been 83
years
but you know like it was it was crazy
man to see it all come together and I'm
just I'm just really I'm really happy
with the finished product
that's so cool and Jessica for you like
what did you love most about this story
oh
what I love most about this story is
um
just seeing these two really funny warm
people fall in love I really love the
environment I feel like Vanessa and
Laura and like kind and
there everybody's really funny and uh
really just
lovely in it I just think it's funny
also and I I'm really into how well the
jokes play and also finally I got to see
it too
um a couple months ago and just the
animation of it is just I hate to be
that person but out of this world
also was it like was it trippy dude no
it made me like it made my hair on my
arm stand up like a couple of the
sequences especially like when we're in
space yeah our characters I mean it is
like just it's unlike anything that I've
I've seen before and so I'm really
stoked to be a part of it yeah also you
know you've got such an amazing cast
Jessica your other your other cast
members here are incredible
um have you guys like did you see each
other while you were working on it or
was it sort of like no not huh no no it
was during the height of covet and and
you know
we kind of had to do separate sessions
based on everybody's schedule you know I
did the majority of my recording in New
Zealand when I was filming uh X in the
beginning of 2021 uh and I aren't even
in the same room right now yeah I mean
this is a split screen
technology see how agency
I need that filter well I don't know
you're in New Zealand yeah yeah yeah and
um great movies so um thank you thank
you so
um you know it was kind of like this
thing that we kind of pieced together
over the years
um and uh
you know it's just we like like we were
saying before we had
Fletcher and Maurice who were you know
really a big help to making sure that
everything was like cohesive and
everybody's energies matched in the
dialogue and like if I said a line like
this then Jessica got that and responded
the right way and if she said something
something improv that she added then I
knew how to respond to that so it was
just like you know a lot of just
building with them and and you know just
having an understanding of the
characters I think I think everybody
involved with this show they got that
script they read that character and they
were like all right I get this I know
what this is you know right on yeah well
congratulations to both of you it comes
across beautifully I'm excited for
people to see it
um and I know like people had said it
was going to be a series before and it's
a special now but it made me want more
yeah don't worry